Well, I am very excited to be here.
This is delicious salad.
I'm so excited.
Watermelon is truly one of my favorite ingredients.
Same
So teach me a ton.
All right, so let's do it.
So we're gonna start with a very simple
and easy kind vinaigrette over here.
So we're going to take our lemon juice in here.
We're gonna add in also some orange juice
and now we're also gonna use the zest of both.
I am a big zest person.
I love zest.
I can never get enough zest.
Never enough.
So we're just going to
zest this in there.
I have a zest for life.
(laughs) Love that.
So we're just going to get in a bunch of our zest in there.
Both the orange zest and the lemon zest in there.
And that's just going to add more kind of aromas
and smells when you're doing that.
It is kind of like the little secret ingredient
to just kind of really boost the flavor.
Then followed by that
we're gonna add in some balsamic vinegar.
Do you like vinegar?
I love vinegar, but I always want it to be in the backseat
and the olive oil to be the driver.
Good call.
I like acid coming from fruit more.
Honestly same.
That's why I do like kind of the two acids
from fruit and the balsamic there.
We add little bit of olive oil into there as well.
And of course some salt and pepper.
Always important.
Any restaurant food you eat,
one of the main reasons it's more delicious
than home food is they just use way more salt
and pepper than anyone would realize.
Now we're going to whisk that up over here,
and now a little trick I do is I'm actually going to
add our watermelon into the vinaigrette before
we add the arugula so we kinda soak some of it up.
So we're going to toss it in here
and then as you can see,
the watermelon gonna almost kind of soak up all that vinegar
and all the lemon juice and the zest.
Then I like to add in the arugula.
But it's very important, if you're entertaining with this,
you really want to do this right before
because the balsamic vinegar has
a dark color and it will kind of just ruin the color
if you do it too far in advance.
That's a hot tip.
Hot tip.
That's what you wanna do.
Hot tip!
So now also very important in salads,
I always love to add in some type of nut
it gives it like a nuttiness,
a little crunch.
So let's add in some walnuts
And kind of like that fattiness.
Yeah you really need the fattiness.
Now let's toss that together.
And finally let's add-
well not finally, we have two more ingredients.
Second to last!
Second to last, correct.
We're going to add in our arugula
which is personally my favorite of all the greens
cause it's really nice and peppery.
It adds so much great flavor.
I love it also with melted cheese in a sandwich.
I'm just gonna say that.
Speaking of cheese,
we also have some crumbled up feta
which will give us even more fattiness.
Some salt is really important.
I think feta's is a great cheese to go
with any type of salad.
It's also sturdy.
It really holds itself up.
So now just toss that together
and Drew that is it.
If you're entertaining it is a very quick recipe to make
to impress your guests
I mean,
we did this in like three minutes Eitan.
Now I know that you're supposed to serve it
in a little bowl.
No we're eating from these.
Okay good.
I love these.
Yeah I'm taking this back to my dressing room later.
Okay good. Perfect.
(muffled voice) I'm really grateful for being invited.
(muffled voice) I'm so glad.
(muffled voice)
I don't think either of us just uttered a word of English,
but we knew exactly what each other meant.
You can hear masticating and delight,
and that's as far as I'm concerned, all that matters.
I absolutely-
god when you hit that feta.
Right.
The fattiness, the saltiness.
And I always look forward to being with you
and I am so lucky to be a culinary contributor with you
or you're the culinary contributor
and I'm your little subject.
Thank you Eitan Bernath.
Go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
for the full recipe
and get your summer on.
(upbeat music)